tv series the bureau is a fictionalized
glimpse into france's intelligence
service
a tense drama punctuated by unforeseen
twists
the spy thrill has long been popular in
france
but more than five years after it was
first broadcast
it's become an international hit
the bureau's executive producer says the
show offers a fresh perspective
it is a french language show it's
ordinary people doing an extraordinary
job in an intelligence and
agency at the ggse the success
in over 120 markets today is because
it's relevant it is an insight that had
not been
seen i mean again you know most of these
shows were either
english or american the show's
distributor says the bureau's global
appeal
has helped change buyers attitudes i
think once you have a success for
example the bureau
it's easier for us to to have some
discussion with the
buyers who usually don't acquire french
series which is the case today now
it's positive for us as a distributor
because we can really
sell some french programs where we
usually never never
you know have any deal on such series
online streaming platforms have made
french shows available to an
unprecedented international audience
call my agents another homegrown french
tv series
attracting fans worldwide the spirited
comedy is set in a talent agency in
paris
run by shrewd entrepreneur hisham
yanovsky
hisham is played by actor assad
i think boundaries have been broken and
people don't mind watching series in
foreign languages
anymore because call my agent is on so
many platforms it's reached a really
wide
public including people in the industry
and that's had a big
impact on new projects on being offered
paris is the backdrop for most of the
shows the world famous louvre features
in the most recent french language hit
lupa
netflix says the mystery thrillers
attracted more than 70 million
subscribers
making it one of the platform's most
watched shows
french tv shows have certainly benefited
from
the surge in people watching series at
home during the covid pandemic
and at a time when few people can travel
a location like paris
certainly offers some welcome escapism
after decades in the shadows of the
country's famous film industry
the french tv industry is clearly having
a moment as more viewers than ever
take a plunge into what was previously
foreign territory
natasha butler al jazeera paris